Have you ever been associated
or affiliated with Chinese Communist Party?
No, senator. Again,
I'm Singaporean.
Of what nation are you a citizen?
Singapore is.
Are you a citizen of any other nation? No. Senator.
Have you ever applied for Chinese citizenship?
Senator, I served my nation in Singapore.
No, I did not.
Do you have a Singaporean passport?
Yes. And I served my military
for two and a/2 years in Singapore.
Do you have any other.
Do you have any other passports from any other.
No. Senator, your wife is an American citizen.
Your children are American citizens?
That's correct.
Have you ever applied for American citizenship?
Not. No, not yet. Okay.
Have you ever been a member of the Chinese
Communist Party?
Senator, I'm Singaporean. No.
Have you ever been associated
or affiliated with the Chinese Communist Party?
No, senator. Again,
I'm Singaporean.
Let me ask you some hopefully simple question.